sur les traces d'une autre histoire
celle qui raconte les résistances les
luttes de femmes méconnu ce groupe de
curieux et de militants féministes s'est
donc retrouvé à ce pour thoune devant
les wind une habitation sucrière dirigé
par l'une des familles les plus
puissantes de l'époque les dubuc en 1831
éclater la fer de lance pour thoune
dirigé par teen et monique né esclave
devenu libre une liberté remise en cause
par les erreurs de l'habitation
sauf que tin sait lire et écrire souvent
au libérer un esclave mais on nous l'a
quand même que les clubs restent
attachés à la famille eh bien il est
décidé qu'à partir de 1827 les esclaves
lorsqu'ils auront des remarques à faire
sur leur maître n'auront pas s'adresser
aux joueurs mais peuvent descendre dans
la commune dans le coup voir le juge de
paix il fait des retours des lunes
centaines d'esclaves
monique conteste la législation du code
noir dans une période d'agitation
général après ce point d'histoire en
direction suite bassignac à quelques
kilomètres de là un des cars entiers de
trinité qui abritait une autre
habitation sucreries nous sommes cette
fois ci en 1923 les ouvriers agricoles
subissent des pestes salaire non
justifiés s'organisent des grèves dit
marchante qui se terminent parfois de
façon tragique en 1923 une fusillade
éclate
laurence mark les ouvrières assistante
est tuée dans la manifestation
elle était enceinte elle avait 19 ans
ici on abat signac
nous avons voulu montrer que les femmes
ont toujours participé aux luttes de
résistance et aux luttes ouvrières
on l'a vu on le verra aujourd'hui dans
les vallées grève ouvriers
à 2914 à massignac on l'a vu aussi dans
la marche la marche ou la faire on l'a
vu aussi dans toutes les luttes anti
esclavagiste le dire des âneries mais
ont toujours été présentée cette
histoire n'est pas écrite
donc c'est important pour nom de le dire
et de faire connaître cette histoire
c'est si justice qui l'aurait conduit
une histoire méconnue qui fait
aujourd'hui l'objet de recherches
assidues
le prochain rendez vous est fixé au 11
novembre au vauclin